mais je crois que la france n'a parlé
cela monsieur de cette gérard cherpion
monsieur le premier ministre la première
préoccupation des français et l'emploi
ce n'est pas la vôtre
votre priorité ce sont les petits
arrangements entre amis quitte à
provoquer une crise institutionnelle
votre priorité c'est votre emploi pas
celui des français par l'absence d'une
politique cohérente tant sur le plan
économique que sur le plan social
vous avez envoyé un million deux cent
mille personnes de plus à pôle emploi
depuis l'élection de françois hollande
la cour des comptes d'ailleurs analysé
le catalogue des mesures mises en place
depuis 2012 et le bilan est lourd de
l'échec cinglant des contrats de
génération à l'explosion des contrats
aidés des emplois d'avenir qui ne sont
plus financés à l'apprentissage que vous
avez cassé vous avez dépensé sans
compter l'argent des français avec un
seul objectif inversée artificiellement
la courbe du chômage
pourtant là encore vous avez échoué
le chômage des jeunes repart à la hausse
celui des seniors poursuit sa hausse
tout le monde paye votre échec la baisse
de 11 mille 700 demandeurs d'emploi pour
ce mois d'octobre serait une bonne
nouvelle si pôle emploi n'avait pas
simultanément radier 50 de 1800
personnes inscrites chiffres en euros ce
chiffre en hausse de 30% sur un an
les français ne sont pas dupes de vos
manipulations statistiques et budgétaire
ils l'ont démontré par leur vote massif
lors de la primaire de la droite et du
centre
le débat aura lieu le premier ministre
il souhaite des réformes de fond
il souhaite sortir du marasme économique
et politique dans lequel vous allez
plonger la france vont ils devoir
attendre mai 2017 ou allez vous tirer
dès maintenant les conséquences de vos
échecs
merci la parole est à madame myriam el
khomri ministre du travail de l'emploi
de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs députés le seul député
cherpion vous m'aviez habitué à plus de
rigueur intellectuelle
quand je vous vois aujourd'hui citait
des chiffres de là
catégories a b c tout mélanger vous
m'aviez en effet habitué à plus de
rigueur intellectuelle
dois-je vous rappeler ici nommé projet
contre projet il faut qu et de
l'honnêteté
dois-je vous rappeler ici qu'une
commission d'enquêté demandée par la
droite au sénat a montré qu'il n'y avait
eu aucune manipulation statistique 2 que
dans la catégorie c'est que vous que
dans la catégorie c quand vous parlez de
1 million de chômeurs de plus près de
50% sont actuellement à temps plein et
cherche un autre emploi dois-je vous
rappeler également s'agissant notamment
du chômage des jeunes que nous avons
atteint le niveau de 2012 et que sous
votre quinquennat
ils avaient augmenté de près de 30% vous
êtes bon de la garantie jeunes je ne
crois pas parce que dans mon bureau vous
me dites que la garantie jeunes est un
dispositif particulièrement efficace
parce que justement il s'appuie sur
l'emploi d'abord vous êtes contre le
plan 500000 formation absolument pas
parce que le président richert et vous
même au sein de la r f rappeler à chaque
fois que ce plan permet justement en
partant des besoins des entreprises
bassin d'emploi par bassin d'emploi à
répondre à cette question des emplois
non pourvus
est ce que vous êtes content également
les contrats aidés lorsque nous savons
pertinemment lorsque nous savons et
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que le plus
haut niveau de contrats aidés en 1997
est ce que vous êtes content quand je
vous rappelle quand je vous rappelle
justement que nous sommes passés de 9 à
15 % de personnes en situation de
handicap sur les contrats aidés
lorsque nous savons pour les jeunes qui
subissent discrimination pour les
seigneurs dont voulez parlez dans votre
question
cela permet justement de retrouver un
emploi et donc de la dignité
non il ya deux réalités de votre
discours cher monsieur serge champions